- Hello beloved drones,
and welcome to the
Seven Million Habits
of Highly Effective
Hampton Deville Employees.
- Habit number 835,
dress for the job
you want, not the job you have.
- Find the person
whose job you want
and dress exactly like them.
- I got my job by dressing
like Kate for two weeks.
- And I pretended to be a man.
- But don't just
dress like them,
you should act like them, too.
- Walk like them.
- Move your arms
around like them.
- Follow them around
with a tape recorder
to record their
voice in meetings
or on the phone, even at home.
- Follow them home.
- Steal their credit
card information.
- Drive their car.
- Kiss their children goodnight.
- Sleep with their wife.
- And their husband.
- That's right,
they're polyamorous.
- Why did you
assume they weren't?
- Let go of whatever
preconceived notions
you have about what a
relationship is or can be.
- It is the 21st
century, god damn it.
- And before you know it,
you'll have their job.